let's talk a little bit about selective
incorporation so you are already likely
familiar that the first ten amendments
of the United States Constitution are
the Bill of Rights Bill of Rights and
especially the first eight of these are
all about protecting individuals rights
so you have those rights and but then
there is a question to what degree are
these rights protected against state
laws and this became a little bit
clearer once the Fourteenth Amendment
came along and just to remind ourselves
here section one of the Fourteenth
Amendment and we really want to zero in
on the due process clause which says nor
shall any state deprive any person of
life liberty or property without due
process of law now some have argued for
total incorporation that says hey look
the Fourteenth Amendments making it
clear that the state cannot infringe on
these rights but what has happened
especially in the United States Supreme
Court is that on various decisions maybe
this was something involving the Fifth
Amendment they've ruled that the rights
described by that amendment can't be
limited by a state law so they would
have selectively incorporated the Fifth
Amendment from the bill of rights and
decision on what the state can and
cannot do and their justification there
is a due process clause of the
Fourteenth Amendment and to make that a
little bit more tangible we can look at
some relatively recent cases in 2008 you
have the case District of Columbia
versus Heller and this is a really
interesting case around the Second
Amendment the District of Columbia
Washington DC had a law that banned
handguns and so one of the residents
challenges that handgun ban and he goes
all the way to the United States Supreme
Court and in the decision on District of
Columbia vs. Heller the United States
Supreme Court says that the District of
Columbia cannot pass a law that violates
Heller's second Amendment rights because
of the Due Process Clause of the
Fourteenth Amendment but that's still
left a little bit of an opening you fast
forward and in 2010 you have another
similar case go to the Supreme Court
this is McDonough
versus Chicago Chicago had a similar
handgun ban and McDonald was a resident
of Chicago and the government in Chicago
argued that okay you know what the
District of Columbia versus Heller does
not apply to us because that was a
federal district and it would not apply
to something that is part of a state
well the Supreme Court disagreed with
Chicago and took the side of McDonald
they selectively incorporated using the
14th amendment as their justification
they said look the state cannot deprive
any person of their liberties and so
they selectively incorporated the Second
Amendment into that decision and it made
it very clear that a state cannot pass a
law that infringes on people's second
Amendment rights so big picture
selective incorporation
it's the doctrine where judicial
decisions incorporate rights from the
Bill of Rights to limit laws from states
that are perceived to infringe on those
rights and the justification comes from
the 14th amendment